[Music]
yes the explanation is that under time
to rest someone have phones up and says
what's the title of your talk I just
couldn't think of anything maisons and
baryons and now I'll look I'll explain
my change of mind later or right brother
shortly I was was going to start out
with a fable or a bad dream that I
thought of in terms of maisons and
baryons which is takes you back to
Schrodinger in his equation whereby he
wrote down the equation as I saw it and
then was embarrassed to find he couldn't
solve the equation but worse than that
none of his colleagues nor anybody else
could do it but came a comforting person
with a text with a futuristic point of
view patients in 80 years will have a
hyper super cyber computer which will
solve your equation and you will get the
binding energy of the hydrogen atom well
I said why is that a story because
that's a way we're caught in a way in
terms of QCD in the non-perturbative
case so I would tendency to move away
from maisons and baryons and then also
in terms of making of cutting down a
30-minute talk on forty or six years to
manageable proportions I look for
another theme and I found it and you'll
see that as a matter of fact it's
naturally taken and that is it's photons
both real and virtual and time like and
space like Dirk actually went through
the rationale in fact more detail than
I'd planned to as to why photons are so
important because we think we understand
them and then the other part of it is
because their flavor free that is to say
then they will latch onto anything with
a charge and they don't care provided
that you have the energy to provide the
mass they don't care what flavor you are
what family you are anything like that
now of course the the prime illustration
of the beauty of photons is also taken
up in other talks at this at these
sessions today and this after this
morning in this afternoon namely the
Freedman Kendall Taylor experiments at
slackin MIT which of course make use of
the space like Photon
and in fact condemned those of us who
were working on Maison baryon to realize
that we weren't dealing with elementary
particles but we're dealing with
molecular chemistry if you please and
then also in the timelike region the
experiments that I'm sure Sam will cover
both first experiments on the production
of vector maisons at Daisy and then
following the E + E - experiments so
that eliminates part of my problems and
now I'll go and I want to do I want to
essentially do a chronology of some of
the things that have happened in the
laboratory
both emphasizing mostly the physics but
occasionally putting a little twist on
it in terms of nostalgia and whatnot and
there's also an apology to the younger
members of this audience who probably is
difficult to conceive of why we were
perplexed by a certain point at a
certain time when the answer was so
obvious well I can only tell you that it
wasn't obvious at the time one of the
first experiments actually Fred alluded
to and this is the photon photons to
produce and in this case PI zero maisons
and and this was in fact was one of the
first experiment that was done at the
300 MeV synchrotron here at MIT
essentially confirmed what you could do
by geometry namely that they were
dealing mostly with a J equal
three-halves residence and that also
that there's an S wave production of pi
zeroes at that time somewhat mysterious
there was another thing that
now was obvious but I know it led to
some controversy at the time is that the
is the coherent production of PI zeros
from nuclei which sounds like perfectly
reasonable quantum mechanics leaving the
nucleus in the ground state but at that
time was controversial because yes
everybody knew about elastic scattering
of things doing going coherently but
producing PI zeros seemed to be another
thing but here was the experiment then
Gill Davidson's thesis on producing PI
zeros and you'll notice as you go to
heavier and heavier nuclei that the
production Peaks for forward more and
more just a fun thing here's a
combination astray ting what we become
part of my thesis if you please namely
we were producing we were producing both
physics and we were also producing
physicists so I label some of these
things with the people's whoever was
thesis and here's Bert Richter's thesis
where the interest there was the
expected the expected let me do it this
way they expected from what you would
expect from the three halves resonance
but on top of that a very actually very
conventional simple photoelectric effect
for producing a PI plus Mesa and and as
evidenced here by the interference term
between the two all of this was very
very very new now there's an it was an
experiment that was done and we called
it then for Dave's and a Bob the for
Dave's being Dave Dave Caldwell de fresh
Dave Hill Dave Ritson and Bob Schluter
being the Bob and their this again is
history up to that time they've been
some measurements of PI proton
scattering in this energy range that it
sort of made a more shot of this thing
there was some bump there but it was not
very clear and here they did a very
careful
job and saw that these were the two and
the fact those are the next two I equal
T ku and a half resonances in the PI on
nucleon system
I added Frank Jenna Jenna V Z's name to
this because it was Frank who with me he
we were making a differential Cherenkov
counter and it was he who pointed out to
me because he was and this was part of
this experiment was he who pointed out
to me that a beam of particles going
through producing Cherenkov light gives
light that looks like a ring of stars
and he said you know we ought to do put
a lens in front of it and and look at
the focal focal plane and you'll see a
ring which will depend upon the velocity
of the particles cute
that's an undergraduate student okay now
moving on and here's some bubble chamber
work and now you probably I should have
outlined here but I want to emphasize of
course the and now even I can't see it
but is the contributions from the MIT
and you recognize the names of Rosen
Singh and Yamamoto and plus who were of
course still with us but yeah I'm a
motive at that time was a graduate
student and this what was this
experiment was in a bubble chamber and
was the production of a two zeros but
the most important thing there was it
was a mystery still the a20 had been
found but there were neutral a neutral
decay that was unexplained that is to
say couldn't be found and it was they
who found that the a20 decayed into two
gammas which was rather extraordinary
because it was competing with the three
pi decay which is a strong interaction
and of course the reason behind that was
a violation of G parity which was
prohibiting the three pi decay of the
ada zero so was unraveled a mystery at
that time then continuing on and now to
the work done at the Cambridge
electronics
and here is a virus fever yawns thisis
where one of the outputs of that was the
discovery of a resonance by looking at
high Q Square high momentum transfer
photo pi zero production here and in
fact this is the the I equals the
isotopic spin three-halves the highest
baryonic resonance I think still extant
and one of the amusing things is if you
do a fruit to Frau cheap lot with these
things is that all those resonances fall
on a nice straight line if you plot J
versus M squared which seems
extraordinarily simple and goes back to
my comments about QCD and my prejudice
that somehow the molecular physics of
quarks may turn out to be simpler than
at least would be indicated by the
computers that have been brought to bear
on that problem okay then next was also
an amusing byproduct of of the
experiments we did in producing photo
zero and PI plus photo production and
here are just for amusement
we took the ratio of the photo
production cross-sections to the PI
scattering single PI scattering
cross-sections and we discovered that
even over a very large range of
cross-sections that is from small
forward angle cross-sections to backward
these points all centered about a ratio
of 0.85 ie roughly 2 pi over alpha well
that was just thrown out as an amusing
thing but also clearly the implication
of it was that the photon is acting very
much like a strongly interacting
particle simply with a reduced coupling
and indeed I believe this was part of
the inspiration for saccharide to
the Vectra dominance model so continuing
with that and continuing on vector
dominance here's another bubble chamber
again this was they called the Cambridge
bubble chamber group and again the names
PLAs rosin sedan yammamoto and of course
this this typical of bubble chambers you
don't get many events but what you get
there fairly clear and that is a bump
where the row 0 should be a production
cross-section indicating a threshold for
it and the important thing was that
indeed confirming the vector dominance
model a gambler the cross-section for
conversion of gamma-rays to Rose was
very large
in other words easy to do now then
because CEA didn't really have the
energy it was a prejudice I guess it was
a prejudice of mind that there was
something smelled wrong with a Reggie
some of you don't have haven't had the
benefit of education in the Reggie and
Reggie models but they were supposed to
be at one time a nice explanation or at
least a parameterization that worst and
possibly even included some physics and
it was our feeling that it was a little
bit artificial and we here was an
experiment where we thought we'd tested
rather severely because we manufactured
polarized photons with a crystal and and
then measured a pipe plus photo
production with polarized photons and
this is the symmetry between one
polarization and the other
that's the Severus test you can put a
model to when you start taking account
the spins of the photon and the
polarizations and indeed we are
gratified to be able to eliminate at
least two models and I think this third
model was had so many parameters in it
that it sort of sunk on its own under
its own weight so in point of fact I
hope we
help to bury the Reggie theory oh I
should say by the way that that and
here's an aside that this was also the
occasion of the what we call the the
perfect diamond caper the to produce the
polarized photons required a perfect
crystal and we had been disappointed by
the the presumed suppliers who were
presuming a beryllium crystal and so we
had everything going including a very
elaborate goniometer we had everything
ready to go we even had the experiment
was all planned out and scheduled there
was only one thing missing we didn't
have the perfect crystal and so we
phoned among others we phoned of course
De Beers we phoned a Rutherford lab we
found various solid-state laboratories
we we phoned the Agra cons diamond
laboratory in India all looking for a
perfect crystal and we did get from
Johns Hopkins we found a man who had a
crystal the court one corner of which
one millimeter was in fact perfect well
with that inspired that nature could do
such a thing I went and got a hold of
Harry Winston who runs a diamond jewelry
store in on Fifth Avenue in New York
very elegant his son had been in the
Rocket Society at MIT and indeed he let
me run through all the crystals I found
a lovely four carat crystal and it
turned out and measuring it on the
outside it was superb and we cut it up
and sure enough it was perfect not quite
but I won't go into that in any event
now I'm going over into time like
photons as opposed to real and I want to
remind something that Martin Mensch
Martin don't mentioned but I would like
to restate namely if you're the one of
the first a plus II - if you please
experiments was done by
Martin and he in fact in this was the
experimental apparatus the air where the
positrons went into a gas and then the
photons were detect detected here but
the important point here's one of the
results which was published in 51 this
is the drop-off and counts due to the
lifetime of the triplet state and then
the clever thing that Martin had done
was to show that he could get rid of the
triplet state by adding gases which
would confer triplet to singlet and
therefore get rid of some of the counts
that he was getting from the triplet
state and so there indeed was the first
if you please a plus e minus
annihilation experiment now the blaze of
an in glory or glory whichever you want
to think of CEA was the last experiment
done in terms of the storage ring there
which of course unfortunately lacked
luminosity and therefore was shut down
here's Harvey Newman's thesis showing
that the e plus e minus scattering was
perfectly good and classical as it
should be but a rather strange result a
rather unexpected result was that the
ratio of hadron production to muon pair
production was much larger than expected
by the quark theories extant at that
time and in fact had risen to much
larger values the fact of the matter is
the points here from Joe's thesis had
shown this before in fact slack got on
the air but Joe being polite or urged
probably by me since the results were
out what he did the thesis put in the
later slack results into his thesis
which would confirmed it now I turn back
to space like photons where we did an
experiment at slack
which was probably one of the firsts at
least the first with a reasonable amount
of andronik results of looking at the
hydronic final state in deep and elastic
electrons scattering and I'll only quote
show you one result we'll know what two
results but one was by looking at the
state and just simply saying making very
simple assumptions like isotopic spin
invariance you could measure from the
hydronic charge ratios in a rather
complex way which I won't go into
something which should give you the
absolute value of the up quark charge to
the down quark charge now you might say
I thought everybody knew that well no
not everybody knew that in fact it
wasn't too clear that there were quarks
you have to put you in that mindset in
order to appreciate some of the silly
things we did at that time and so of
course you get as usual you've got we
got as you should a factor of two that
is in retrospect another result of that
experiment was simply looking at the
plus two minus ratio and comparing it in
a funny way with what we got what was
available from neutrinos that is to say
once a quark has emitted a positive a
leading positive maze on it presumably
leaves the leading quark in the down
state at which case you would expect to
get a minus Mazin as the leading quark
or you would expect to get the same
thing you get from a neutrino experiment
ok so we looked at that and indeed here
the neutrino points and then here's the
plus the minus 2 plus ratio for the for
the maisons coming off that thing and
indeed that was pretty it was nice by
the way that line and people who know me
know that that I always lapse into a
mood of having explaining I had run
hadron ization model of my own
and and this line is the prediction for
that ratio I gave it originally the
history of that I gave it originally as
a homework problem in 805 the quantum
mechanics course because it's very easy
to do okay and so this is what you get
out of an 8:05 explanation for
hybridization works very nicely by the
way though and it's the granddaddy of
those models it came before Fineman
field and and clearly before lund now
vite Busha and now i depart and make an
exception this is not about photons the
Busha had a nice ideas about hadron
ization he said you should be able to
find out about hadron ization if you
look at how it occurs in nuclear
material that is to say the nuclear
medium somehow you expect will affect it
and that should reveal something about
the head realization mechanism and in
fact here's a nice simple experiment
done at Fermilab by Busha and other
colleagues in the counter spark chamber
group and you see that the end result
was as follows that if you look at the
forward going particles this is plotted
versus rapidity that you cannot very
readily distinguish the the difference
between the forward the both the number
and the distribution of the high
rapidity particles indicating therefore
that in some sense the hybridization
must be taking place outside the nuclear
material since it seems to be unaffected
by it and now and that actually for the
time being and possibly more created an
industry in the use of nuclei and
production off nuclei both as an
indication of the hadron ization process
but also as we shall see
an indication of how the quark itself
interacts with nuclear material
well actually won't see because I don't
have any material in that we did the
same thing at that same with electoral
production on nuclei and all I can say
about that because this is a little bit
too complicated but essentially these
are different elements and the
distribution in momentum and the
distribution in per P perp and a way of
summarizing that result is that and
point of fact in the same way that was
found in the nuclear material at the
Fermilab experiment you cannot
distinguish a jet that has been produced
in LED or nuclei of heavy nuclei from
the jet of hadrons produced in deuterium
again indicating that the hybridization
takes place outside what's the time here
ok how long ago was it was found that
photons and again because of a vector
dominance of photon is frequently a row
and we'll hear more about that and
therefore when you bombard nuclei with
photons you find indeed that they there
is what's called a shadowing namely the
photon on LED does not look like photons
times 208 nucleons but is less and
here's an experiment which we've just
finished a t6e 665 at Fermilab
indicating the same thing that is to say
here it's done with deep inelastic
scattering for muons and you see though
it's the ratio is around 1 here as you
go to 2 small x fun xbj indeed finally
the numbers of shadowing from virtual
photons begins to agree in very small X
with what you get from photons
all right and now I shift in praise of
gluons virtual and real whatever that
means with respect to gluons and why
praise of well here's a transparency of
something that Fred Epling showed namely
the gem detector for the super collider
and was by way of introduction to the
fact that having told you something in
the past let me tell you a little about
the present and of course the the the
the challenge here is for you to find
the person in this picture so let me say
that we're coming along the first chain
we have built we our group is primarily
interested in doing the muon part of the
chambers for that experiment we've
started on that and indeed we have just
made and are about to test one chamber
which is of a reason but approximately
kind of lengths we talk about making
except that we'll have to make something
like 900 of these and this is a first
test and the and the data reduction
panel here for such a thing but then
that's pretty far in advance so what to
them how to amuse ourselves in the mean
time well we do have various projects
both the CDF and the gran sasso project
and so on and I'm clearly by the way for
the time being I'm like I'm letting Sam
is going to take care of himself so I'm
talking about I'm not covering the
Kendall Freedman experiments or the all
the nice work that the Sam ting group is
done
but in the meantime here with the Busha
Steve Stedman Ernie wodsworth and
whatnot have put in a letter of intent
for an experiment a trick and that thing
is busily going along and expects to be
running some time in 97 and let's see
and to punctuate if you notice that one
of the implications of the
transparencies I was showing was that we
were not only producing physics but we
were producing physicists yes even
laboratory directors and so it's rather
topical that I present is the last
something to do with Cobie namely the
hero of that particular result was
George Smoot and George Smoot was one of
Dave Rich's students PhD students and
I'd like to say that the reason George
saw saw the light was by virtue of his
great training under Dave's leadership
by the way this is not to be confused as
I was for a while with those of you who
live around here there's not to be
confused with the Smoot which is a unit
of measurement for the Massachusetts
Avenue Bridge and refers to an Oliver
Smoot who was apparently very stiff
enough one evening to have been used as
a measuring stick so I'll end on that
note